I'm never lien Israeli hello I'm Ben I'm
from Israel hi I'm Rachel and I am
representing the u.s. today hi I'm Emily
I am from the United States today we're
gonna be swapping some snacks
have you ever have any Israeli food or
snack before I feel like I may have had
is really food from friends and things
like that but I've never really had any
like snacks have you ever had these
early snack before never
I can't even I don't even know I don't
know no never
okay let's go I'm excited to go all
right
[Music]
this is the incredible mighty beastly
which is inconsistent of a very very
young flavored with snap and I eat these
now because we know my literal favorite
these are Cool Ranch Doritos which is
one of the best flavors ever known to
man it's kind of like got a little zest
got a little ranch flavor
I'm saying they never had these before
I've never even seen it all right now
we're swapping it why it's really good
it's really good so great ginger really
good you want to do the ease right away
you have to I want to do this really he
leads you have to feel it feel it do you
mean each one of them can I tell you
something on my life that is how I eat
these
I'm so weird about the way that I do
things I only like a bird and I like
okay you're so he's really layer
I don't know why I do i they taste
delicious the flavor is really
interesting are you like this or like
this more why do you look more I like
them they're gonna like this back fine
hey these are great and I love them but
I also love dorita
[Music]
lays barbecue
this is the mighty beastly falafel this
is a bite uh-huh
Lee is to me okay so bite to me okay
Lee's Lee got it right to me people
is it good it has nothing to do with I
don't care it seems like it's gonna be
all right
don't eat too much okay I'll save some
for you
these look weird it looks kind of like
bunny food right yeah looks like rabbit
food it's actually cockroach these are
great I usually don't like the barbecue
taste but this is great really mm-hmm
they're really hard they don't taste
like much it's like salt and pepper
I would eat these I like it's just such
an interesting different flavor I think
I like them if I had to choose out of
lays barbecue chips and these are pick
these all day I would pick that one
woman potatoes always win over weed
right if I had to pick one of these I
definitely go for the BBQ chips
so these are fantastic obviously you've
had Nutella before yes everyone in the
world has had Nutella before so this is
bomba that's actually it sounds cute
actually you combine it with busy
sometimes Beasley yeah if you're a prior
snack yeah
put the basically inside the Baba and
you just leave it anyway
why step wise and write together here
you are
enjoy two for one no oh my god oh yeah
[Music]
yeah that's really good
oh my God look at that it just looks
good yeah eat that this looks like a
cheese curl but it's peanut I really
like these that was so interesting Wow
what I feel like I like this more
without a chocolate yeah no you don't
have a big sweet tooth - you know I
thought it was a cheese doodle but it's
not a cheese doodle I mean you have the
consistency of it but it's also like
salty and has a peanut flavor to it
oh yeah yeah this is the thing so when
you reach the age of six you stop to do
this the hammer this is called a hammer
no way after the age of six you go like
this just like no way no way and you
know it's sometimes the bomber takes
over so we just make a spaceship like
this and then
I'm home again that is really innovative
you put this one inside a bumper like
your teeth not oh yeah and then you have
a candy sleep combo candy whatever okay
and then you eat it together that's so
good it's really good right so oh my god
good I've never had anything like this
before in my life like this melts in
your mouth it's like sweet but it's not
super sweet like you can eat all of
these I'm probably not feel bad about
yourself
I prefer of course the easy winner bomba
I almost never eat one I haven't
uploaded out of the two I prefer these
to use chocolate para and but i scowl in
hebrew boom boom
we have the XL size of Hershey's cookies
and cream one of my personal favorites I
feel like there was a moment in time in
which I was eating this every day for
six months it's also called depression
this is really good I think that you're
definitely gonna like this one
let's swap a room yes I hope you like
that so I have happy to give you that
happy to do that I'm gonna have a little
piece of cow here mmm
oh my god magical the hair [ __ ] the
white one is amazing with all the
cathouse it just seems like they care
more than we - this is the best ever
thing I don't care how much sugar how
much I care about sugar anymore
no drug bite would you suck it that's
what I was thinking I'm just gonna stop
on I was like we're gonna be here a
while
you taco with more chocolate really very
aggressive I'm not a big leaf chocolaty
yeah I don't Baddeley about it you have
to smile Sates I love it I love
I love this so much this is so great
it's very much a milk chocolate but
great flavor like I would easily eat
stuff like this it has a consistency of
chocolate like it's chocolate and then
the little crunchies on the inside is
really nice but i just-i can't--
the flavor there like the aftertaste is
chocolaty but while I'm eating it it's
almost like flavorless I think out of
the two I would pick her she's cooking
definitely here yeah her she's cooking
good white window yo yeah yeah white one
all day yes
Hershey's is the best chocolate in
America I think all around the world
then I've tried talk about hunks and yes
I tried in Dubai I'm Switzerland from
Belgium it's just so sweet and that's
why it's so good I felt like I got a
good idea of different Israeli snacks
hopefully I felt like what the ones that
we had brought to represent the u.s.
we're like pretty accurate and like
those are like typical things that like
I'm always eating and things like that I
love that you can combine those two the
Beasley in though
yeah oh man that's great I've never had
anything that tastes like that before
and it's fun to do I will always prefer
bomba bomba over everything
oh wow do you know bomba NBC it comes
together it's like a yeah it can be
along with it yeah maybe the sweet and
sour yeah mmm the chlorines yeah those
are great
I think it can fight the Beasley Adama
yeah I think so yeah I think they're
different but they're similar enough in
their differences yeah I think they
could fight I think or Antron win though
but know this in bomba I don't know
about that
[Music]